you
all right good morning everyone
christina we all sat
this is a house election law committee
we are here for public hearings an
executive session on a number of bills
before we get going on our business i
ask that everybody recite the pledge
with me
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
you everyone um as stated we have public
hearings beginning at 9 30 between 9 30
and our 10 o'clock hearing we we will be
doing an executive session
on one bill
and we will proceed with the rest of our
public hearings for the morning
we will then take a break and begin
executive session this afternoon so with
that
i'm going to open the public hearing on
11 53
11 53 is relative to absentee ballot
requests and with us to introduce the
bill is representative peter tarosian
from atkinson welcome representative to
that side of the table thank you madam
chair and
good morning to
you and the distinguished members of
this committee
for the record my name is peter teroshan
i represent rockingham county
district number 14 which is the town of
atkinson in
plaistow i'm here as a prime sponsor of
house bill 1153 relative to absentee
ballot requests
this is a pretty straightforward and if
you look at the language it's a pretty
short
amendment
and what this bill does it clarifies
that an absentee ballot
may not be you know in this we're
talking about an official absentee
ballot may not be mailed to
an absentee voter before that absentee
voter
has um
signed up and
and
is listed in the town as a voter
so in other words right now under
current law
anybody can request an official absentee
ballot and you don't have to be a
registered voter
what this
bill does
it amends rsa 657 colon 12
in 657 12
states that upon a
properly executed application for an
absentee official absentee ballot for
general election whether the form is
supplied by the secretary of
secretary of state the federal
official postcard or a written statement
containing the information required by
irsa 657 colon 4.
i a town or city clerk shall forward or
ascertain if the
applicant
on the checklist is on the checklist for
the town if they're not an absentee
official absentee ballot won't be
uh mailed
upon so if somebody is rejected of
getting an absentee ballot because then
they haven't registered yet they can
then register to vote if they're
legal and a resident of that town to
to vote they can
register to vote in such time an
absentee ballot will be sent to them so
this kind of puts
the horse before the car instead of the
other way around
it's it's a common sense bill
that
requires that you are
registered to vote before you get an
official ballot and and the reason for
this is to ensure that um
again it's a vote integrity
item
it's important to keep track of ballots
and if we have a bunch of ballots
floating around going to somebody that's
not registered to vote that's
problematic so this cleans it up and
i hope you support the bill and with
that i'll take any questions that the
committee may have do committee members
have a question
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you so does that mean that say uh
someone who was disabled and homebound
would have to make two
efforts to would have to register to
vote
by mail and then make another effort to
get the absentee ballot after doing that
so
there's no exclusion in this anybody
that wants to vote in new hampshire has
to be
registered to vote before they get the
absentee ballot
having said that
the application can be sent in and you
don't have to so let's say you want to
go down to the town clerk to register to
vote you can do that
but you don't have to make another trip
if you're going to vote by absentee
ballot you can send your request in
this simply says you have to take care
of step one first being registered step
two is then apply for the ballot
question
we're here representative bergeron ah
thank you madam chair
just a question there is a provision in
state law
and i don't think it's this provision
it's another one
where if someone is registering to vote
by mail
they have
the right to request an absentee ballot
at the same time
and
both the voter registration application
and the absentee ballot are sent to the
polls on election day
first the voter registrar has to
determine whether the person is eligible
to be registered or not and if so then
the moderator can rule on whether or not
to cast the ballot is it your intent to
do away with that uh procedure
well again it the the
the intent is
to do as i as i
mentioned in testimony here to ensure
that when somebody
applies for the absentee ballot
that they're registered before that is
sent from the town clerk
nothing in this language prevents
somebody that wants to go down and same
day register from doing that so it
doesn't preclude that um
but it again it's it's
it's a
it's to prevent somebody getting an
absentee official absentee ballot that
is not
at that point in time legally registered
to vote
the secretary of state's office has
signed up to speak on this bill further
questions
representative moorehead thank you madam
chair um
thank you representative i'm sitting
behind you unfortunately but i can see
you in the corner there's a mirror maybe
we can
so if the intent you're adding one
sentence
this bill would add one sentence to
rsa 657-12
and that one sentence says that under no
circumstances shall a clerk mail a
ballot
unless
a person has submitted an absentee
ballot application so no ballot without
first an application that's what's being
added
there's nothing in the is there anything
here that has that speaks to whether
someone's been registered
i think this one sentence as i read it
only speaks to whether someone has
already submitted an application
thank you for the question well it
amends the rsa 657 colon 12
and and that's where it
indicates that um you have to be
registered to vote prior to the town
clerk
sending the ballot the absentee ballot
further questions
my understanding is this already occurs
in manchester we don't mail out ballots
thank you for the question
representative um i consulted with the
uh now retired secretary of state on
this
and he indicated that there are cases
where absentee ballots go out and in
fact and i can't speak for the current
secretary of state but but the then
secretary of state
supported
the idea of making this amendment
thank you
seeing none thank you representative
terozian also signed up to speak on this
bill is
good morning
uh dan healy representing new hampshire
city and town clerks association um and
we oppose this bill
uh basically for the reasons that
representative bergeron just mentioned
we do currently
have some
circumstances where we send out absentee
ballots
requests the request form to people that
are um
currently registered they have the apps
they request the absentee registration
packet and along with that we send the
request form to them
they would need to fill out everything
have it approved
before their ballots
counted
so there are a few circumstances
we do have
some residents that will write a letter
requesting an absentee ballot and we'll
take that as their initial request we'll
send the absentee request form along
with the ballot
they need to complete that request form
before their ballots
counted
so we don't actually count any ballots
without a request on file but there are
a few circumstances where it's
beneficial to send out the request
along with the ballot
people call a few days before an
election they don't have a printer they
might be elderly they don't have access
to print out the application and send it
to us
so to save some back and forth we do
send the requests
with the belt we get that back but
none of our ballots are counted unless
there's a request attached to it
so i'd be open to any questions
questions from committee members for mr
healey
seeing none thank you i have a question
representative o'brien
so uh
what you're saying is sometimes this is
this would be people who are not
registered for whatever reason but they
want to get an absentee ballot would
this be
people who are in a nursing home in
derry who
things like that yeah sometimes it is is
the nursing homes um
we have made a point to go to the
nursing homes uh the past year or two
it's been a little bit more difficult so
we'll send the absentee registration
packets and and all that along with the
absentee requests and they get help from
the the staff they're filling it out
it's it's college students that
just turned 18 their way at college they
want to vote in derry where they live
so they'll request the absentee
registration packet
and they'll want to vote in that
election too so we'll send them the
request
and if it's you know
close to the election we'll send the
bell too but they have to complete
everything everything has to be done
correctly if their absentee registration
is not done correct and the supervisors
reject them their bell gets rejected if
they send the registration but not the
absentee ballot request there's no
request for that belt the ballot gets
rejected so they still have to have
everything done and complete
and sent back to us for the ballots
account so we're not just sending out um
ballots to people um
they have to have everything all their
paperwork has to line up
further questions for
representative lane
um thank you madam chair so if this bill
passes
it's going to be a lot of extra work
for both your for the staff and for the
person trying to vote
so if this bill passes we'd have to do
everything in steps
so the first step would be if they're
not registered to send them the absentee
registration
once they get that
we couldn't send the belt along with
anything basically so it would require a
little bit more mailing
and it might
make it so someone doesn't have enough
time depending on how close the election
to
to get their belt back to us depending
on when they do the request
i mean they should be doing the request
with with time but people don't always
do that it's a few days before but if we
send the request with the ballot um
then they're able to get it back to us
in time
further question
um thank you um so
just based on your experience how much
time
then should someone be requesting this
if they're going to go to this two-step
process a month
i would i would say the earlier the
better we have the forms available like
we have the town election coming up if
someone is away and they and they're not
going to be back we could send them the
absentee registration now so when
someone calls we always recommend
you know the earlier the the better but
i'd say at least a few weeks to if we're
going back and forth with the paperwork
further questions
representative barry
i just want to clarify something that
you said because it struck me so you
said you don't just send votes out to
just anyone
but my understanding is
yours are sending ballots out to just
anyone because you you said
that if i call up your office and i say
hey i'm
you know i live in derry uh it's let's
say it's a week before the election
right yeah um
i i need to request an absolute ballot
you're going you just said you are going
to send me a ballot
yes you said that right
so we would send about um so if you
don't have a printer or you don't have a
way to get the application to us we
would
in circumstances we will send a belt
along
with the application but you have to
complete that and we're not sending it
to just anyone they have to initiate a
contact with us so a phone call or
whatever to us first
requesting
that you know they're looking to vote in
that election
it's it's mainly for the people
the people that utilize it now are the
ones that don't have a printer or they
don't have a way of getting the
application in time there's
there would be no no way that they would
have time to vote
if we didn't send it brian
thank you uh okay so in thank you for
that and i have uh further question if
said if you go through that situation
and you send the ballot and the the
request for registration and then the
supervisors of the checklist don't
accept that
registration there's some problem they
don't have the paperwork correct
something's going on
they don't have proof of residency that
they've sent in
and then they send you the absentee
ballot what happens to the absentee
ballot in that case so the absentee belt
would be marked as rejected
um and it gets stored uh with all the
other election materials for the 22
month retention period um if it's a
state or federal election
and then if it's a a town it would be
stored for 60 days and then disposed of
but it would not be
counted further questions from committee
members
mr hilly i have a question can you
recall a time when you were requested
a ballot either by phone or in writing
where it was not sent
you mean the bell was not returned to us
no when it that somebody requested a
ballot either by phone or in writing on
whatever because you said even if i just
write it on a piece of paper without the
application yeah can you recall a time
when you did not then send the ballot i
i cannot so if we get a request we would
thank you for coming thanks
also signed up to speak on this is rusan
chester
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members um
i know you folks have heard from me a
lot so i'm going to try and keep it
brief
what i think this bill does and i think
it's very very necessary
there are other bills out there that is
uh being considered with regards to
college students being able to vote
remotely that they can that they can
actually sign up to they can actually
request an absentee that they can
actually request the pro
process six months before
the election that they want to vote in
if they if they're going to turn 18
before the election day so
with regards to college students i don't
think that that's causing a problem
because to be honest with you with
responsibility with
with privilege comes responsibility and
you folks have heard a lot of problems
with voter integrity in our state and a
lot of it says they say it's because of
the college students i don't know i'm
not involved in that process however it
would it would
allow
the people of new hampshire that don't
trust our election integrity a bill like
this would put a little bit back in
their hands
the previous
speakers spoke a little bit about now
the town is going to
the
nursing homes and my town has a lot of
nursing homes and assisted livings
we had more people vote from app by
absentee ballot in from those facilities
than we ever have before now am i saying
there's something nefarious going on
i don't know i didn't do i haven't done
the canvassing for my town however it
has raised concerns
i know
absolutely that i have
since
the 2020 election i have
people that live in some of these
assisted livings and nursing homes and
said oh i've never voted
and i've gone to my town hall and they
were registered as voting in 2020.
that's a reality now did it happen
from my town clerk
did it happen from the director of the
nursing home
i don't know the way our laws are set up
is it makes transparency almost
impossible because we allow the director
of the nursing home
to to
say these are all legitimate ballots
these are all legitimate i went down my
entire list of residents and requested
ballots for them and they signed and i
got the absentee ballots they filled it
out and i'm authorizing that they're all
legitimate so that's taking that's
that's
to me that's putting the our town clerk
in a bad position
our town clerk is now saying i have to
trust this director
this executive director that that
they're being honest with these ballots
that's not a good place for even the
best town clerk in the world to be um
that and now with regards to i want to
talk a little bit about what also what
happened in my town in 2020 and i don't
think
i i don't know how it happened but i
know i have
one
undeclared
one democrat and one republican living
in my house
i know
that the undeclared person
received an absentee ballot without
requesting it
in the primary election not the general
election but in the primary election
they received an absentee ballot with
with um
uh actually i think it was before it was
after the primary and before the general
election
no primary you have to declare right so
it was before the primary delay primary
election
that um
it was before the primary election they
received the application to change their
change their party and an absentee
ballot
only one of the two apps and ct ballots
so if they chose to let's say they
filled out the paperwork and wanted to
be a democrat
they only received one of the two
ballots either a republican ballot or a
democrat ballot
and i'm not going to get into it here
which one they receive but definitely
speaks to issues with integrity do i
know that came from the town absolutely
not i don't because it was a p.o box and
it's not the po box that our town uses
so again we're talking about integrity
of elections here in the state of new
hampshire we're first in the nation we
should be above reproach
especially when it comes to election
integrity and i think that this one
little sentence right here does not
prevent
folks
from um from exercising their right
but it puts some responsibility and
integrity back into that process lastly
our town clerks you you heard from the
last representative or the last person
that spoke
that our town clerks
have a really hard job when they get
those when they get those ballots back
they have very limited time right now
this would give them more time to do
their job correctly
and i believe that there would be it
would be less likely to have so right
now
you send your absentee ballot in if you
made a mistake your vote didn't count
and you never know
unless you know enough to go online and
look it up because my town's very good
it'll say right there did you vote in
this election yes or no
um i'll speak to the special election
that we had last year
special election we had last year in my
town
i was out of town i asked for absentee
ballot i used um
i used a
service that would ensure that it was
mailed to me in time and mailed mail to
my home and then it was mailed to me
because i was out of town unexpectedly
and that i mailed it back to my town all
within the time period
when i went online
my vote didn't count
i don't know why i don't know that it
wouldn't
my vote wouldn't have made a difference
in that special election that one if it
had been one vote
i would have made a deal about it but it
wasn't
but the bottom line is is that the
reason why
you have heard a lot from me
over the last couple of months is
because we need to prove
we have lack of trust
we need to we need to stop the divide
and come together and say
i don't think my town's guilty
i don't think my town clerk's guilty i
don't think i don't think my moderator's
guilty i don't even know if the machines
are guilty at some point let's put
integrity back in these elections a
little even if it's only a little bit at
a time and this is a good start
miss chester
i'm not seeing any thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
katie gargano from the secretary of
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee my name is katie gargano
and i'm representing the secretary of
state's office
uh the first thing i'd like to note is i
was not aware of the representative's
intent to not send a ballot without
being registered first i didn't
i didn't read that
in the existing um
bill so i'm gonna have to check with our
secretary of state
dave scalin on how this would affect our
current process of doing absentee
ballots well we might be able to ask him
yes
perfect timing that he walked in the
room
um but
but he knows even if he's secretary of
state he's going to need a pink card
okay
so we were originally
in support of this bill because it
reinforces the existing requirements to
request an absentee ballot and ensures
that best practices are followed by our
town and city clerks
but i definitely think that
there may be some other
rsas that have to be amended to to to do
his full intent if he doesn't want
ballots sent without them being
registered first
thank you further questions
any questions sorry representative lane
just to clarify sorry
just to clarify
you were the opinion that it wasn't
requiring
that it wasn't prohibiting sending the
ballot
correct it's written
correct okay
thank you in the existing law yeah it's
it says that you can still send a ballot
with the paperwork if they're not
further questions from committee members
seeing none thank you
thanks
is there anybody else who wants to speak
to this bill
i don't know that it's necessary i think
the witness just answered that
current law requires allows sending the
ballot with
the actual application form
all right i'm not seeing any other
questions i have no other pink cards if
if um
where did representative derozan go
could you come up with the pad for me
i'm not relieving you of your usual duty
here
and christina i don't have the
electronic
comment sheet that i usually have
um and today um we have persons who have
signed up in regards to 11 53
and of the people who have
um
signed up and not spoken
one
two in favor
and
one
two
three opposed
so thank you everyone and with that i'm
going to close the public hearing on 11
53.
um our next
noticed item is a public hearing on
1324 at 10 o'clock
however in accordance with the noticed
ability to hold executive session
on pending
legislation at any time throughout the
day
i am convening or beginning executive
session on
hb 1496.
i'm just so everybody who's listening
know i did albeit last night let
everybody on the committee know that we
were going to be doing this and we will
be taking a short break afterwards this
is required because of this chairs
failure to recognize last week that when
we continued discussion on this bill to
allow a member to make an amendment it
is an early bill
which means it needs to be reported out
of committee today
i thought i had been clever and gotten
everything done last week
so this needs to happen this morning
because it needs to get in the calendar
that's being published today for session
next week
so
with that we have
1496 you have
also received an amendment that was the
reason we had continued it
it is amendment number 2022 634
is there a motion on
hb 1496 representative barry uh yes
madam chairman i move that we adopt
amendment uh
2022-0634-h
thank you representative sweeney seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
uh yes madam chairman we heard about um
this bill this is the bill that allowed
um anyone to have
access to the electronic copy of the
statewide voter database
from the secretary of state's office uh
we heard extensive debate about it
basically the conclusion that i came to
was that
belief that i've held always is that the
voter list is in fact public information
how you vote is private the fact that
you vote is not
um but
listening to the privacy concerns um
it's it i tried to find a middle ground
and a path forward so that the secretary
of state's office wasn't inundated with
tens of thousands of requests for copies
of the statewide database
but the simple fact of the matter is
that the database is public you can go
into any town clerk's office or wherever
the town is hosting that voter checklist
and you may view that checklist
currently
you may also request physical copies of
that checklist
but you may not get an electronic copy
so what i did was a min 1496 so that any
registered voter of a town may request
the voting list from that town so they
do not get access to the statewide list
but if you are you know throughout town
out you are in bedford a bedford
registered voter may request from the
bedford town clerk or supervise the
checklist an electronic copy of the
bedford checklist
i put in certain kind of stop points so
that you don't have somebody submitting
a request you know day after day after
day they can only request it once per
month
and the town clerk or moderator only has
to provide a checklist that is current
up until the last month so that way they
don't have to pull
a new checklist every single day
they can pull a checklist hypothetically
on the first of the month and dole that
checklist out for the remainder of the
month
um so that is uh that is what i i did
there
um and i'm happy to do am i allowed to
take questions in a second
i'm happy to take to take questions or
the occasional grilling
um
and i hope we pass this
all right
um
we did have a discussion on this we did
hear from the
former dean of the house as to privacy
issues and a couple of other things
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair um
i'm going to vote against the amendment
and if adopted i'll be voting against
the original bill
par partly because
in some aspects the changes really
aren't needed
uh beginning with line seven where
the checklist shall be furnished as a
physical copy or an electro electronic
copy in spreadsheet form or using comma
separated files is existing law already
says
the supervisors of the checklist may
provide the public check checklist on
paper disk tape electronic transfer or
any other form so
existing language already covers this
this proposed amendment
the second objection i have is that
electronic lists shall be the version
updated within the last 31 days the
supervisors of the checklist do not meet
every month
a voter registration form is an
application to be added to the checklist
and it's only when the supervisors of
the checklist actually take the action
to add these people's names to the
checklist are they added to the
checklist so i don't know if this is
going to imply or require that the
supervisors of the checklist meet every
month uh so that that's kind of vague
there
and then although i appreciate the the
change
that the sponsor of the amendment has
made
uh limiting the availability of these
lists to uh residents of the respective
town or city the checklist is available
for public inspection in the clerk's
office at any time
i i still think it's an intrusion on a
person's privacy to to make this
available in a broader uh broader way
and i really don't see any need for it
um
i i just i just think it's invasion of
privacy at this point it's public
information anybody can view it
but i don't think it needs to be
distributed in electronic form
thank you
further discussion on the motion on the
floor which is
enough to adopt the amendment
thank you madam chair um i would like to
ask the
representative barry um
it says here the supervisor of the
checklist or city or town clerk shall
furnish one or more physical copies or
an electronic copy in spreadsheet form
is that at the discretion of the
the supervisor checklist or clerk
whether they provide physical or
electronic or is that at the
um
discretion of the person requesting i'm
not sure that i see the clarity here
thank you representative so uh lines
nine to ten electronic copies shall only
be available to residents of the
respective town um
electronic list shall be the version
updated um but the way i would read it
is the shall furnish is leaving the
discretion to the person requesting it's
clearly the intent of the bill
that
and of the of the amendment that it
shall be
shall be up to the person requesting it
i don't
i i guess if you really want i i don't
read it like that but i guess if you if
you wanted to get really into the into
the into the legal aspect of it but no
definitely the the legislative intent is
it shall be furnished in electronic form
if it is requested as such
um also uh
that that um to to representative
bergeron's point it is not the intention
that they will be meeting every day
every 31 days it's just the most current
version within the last 30 days so if
they haven't updated it
then
further discussion on the motion on the
floor which is the adoption of an
thank you representative muirhead thank
you thank you madam chair representative
barry is there a difference between the
public checklist
in rsa 34 roman numeral 2 which your
minute which your bill addresses
and
what uh would be provided
uh by the secretary of state rsa 30
654-31 roman numeral
four
where it says you get the the list of
registered voters and voter history so
i'm really wondering does voter history
is voter history included in
this part of the law that your bill
addresses um i i do not believe that it
is because it's the it's the copy of the
checklist that's publicly available so
it's the electronic version if you were
to walk into the town of hanover's town
clerk's office and look at the checklist
it would be the electronic version of
thank you
madam chair
representative
thank you representative
barry i mean i hear what you're saying
about you intended for it to be at the
discretion of the person making the
request
but i don't think that when you read it
that that's
necessarily what it says so my question
to you is do we need another amendment
sorry if we have time for that at this
point um i mean if if we need to clarify
it i'm happy to work with the senate on
it i don't want to see this go away
um i'm not i'm not gonna go out go die
on the hill of language and that's the
intent but i will i'm happy to fix it um
if that gets you on board i will commit
to that um and if it does need to be
tightened up i'm happy to do that but i
don't know if we have time at this point
to do that
further questions i will say i had an
amendment sent to me
um
late yesterday afternoon i said yes
that's what i want and i just sent it an
email saying am i confused am i getting
another amendment so
i think there's a lot happening across
the street right now
any further discussion on the
moti on the motion which is before us
which is to pass
amendment 634 to house bill 1496.
seeing none i'm going to ask my clerk
representative hayward who has gallantly
stepped in
to assume these duties because
representative wells was not able to
come today uh representative hayward
would you call the role the motion is
to amend 1496 with amendment number
2022-6348
representative
yes
representative prudhomme o'brien
representative sweeney yes
clerk is a yes
representative tarosian
representative berry
yes
representative groen yes
representative quayley
representative ward no
representative lane
no
representative hamlet no
no representative barry you clearly said
representative
first time through
and the chair yes you're doing a great
job we we it is fine don't worry it's
i just heard a noise from that corner
and i assumed you had all voted
madam chair the vote is ten in favor
all right the bill before this committee
at this point is
hb 1496 as amended is there a further
discussion
is there a motion uh representative
barry uh yes madam chairman i am motion
that we um we adopt
hb
1496 as amended
is there a second i second that madam
chair
representative sweeney seconds it
is there further discussion on the
motion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
representative mcdonald
yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
and clark says yes
representative terosia yes
representative berry
yes
representative groan yes
representative quayley yes
representative uh
i'll vote no too while you're at it
that would be representative ward
representative ward thank you thank you
representative hamer no
no
madam chair
yes
vote is 10-8 thank you
um
1496 will be reported as otp a we are
going to break
until 10 30 and i apologize that we're
putting public hearings behind the eight
ball here this morning we're going to
break until 10 30 to allow the majority
and minority to complete a report
um so this may be sent out to be in the
calendar next week to meet with house
guidelines again my apologies this is my
fault for not recognizing it was an
early bill last week
we are in recess until 10 30. christina
oh let me ask everybody has anybody else
had a green light flashing on their mic
okay christina we had an issue with
these mics last time with them going red
green red green
and it is happening again today madam
chair i can clarify that so green means
that you're the next one waiting in line
there's only a certain amount of
microphones that can be on at the same
time red means it's on green means
you're next in line and green means
members leave them on for too long all
right and i'm leaving mine on all the
time all right i'll be a little more
viligent about asking people to turn
them off okay thank you all right 10 30
we'll be back everybody quick writing
please
five minutes late all right it is 10 30.
this is the election law
committee of the new hampshire house of
representatives we are reconvening after
a recess we have done the public hearing
on our first bill this morning we had to
deal with a matter for executive session
and we are now back in public hearing
the next noticed bill for public hearing
is hb 1324
establishing a formula to allocate
presidential electors to presidential
nominees i have one pink card and that
would not be somebody that would be
entitled to introduce the bill so i want
to thank representative alexander for
standing up for it and representative
alexander
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is joe
alexander i represent hillsborough
district six town of goffstown um i am
just here on behalf of my colleague as a
favor to introduce bill hb 1324
um i am not taking a position for
against i'm just here as a favor so with
that um the bill's introduced i will not
thank you also signed up to speak on hb
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee my name is alvin c i live in
loudoun and i'm
opposed to this bill
this bill
is
to change the way the presidential
electors
are
allocated from new hampshire after a
presidential election currently we
allocate all four electors
as a group to whoever wins the highest
number of votes for the president
uh this bill
based on
on
proportion
of votes
for
candidates uh it's
and
based on this
most likely
every presidential election
two votes would go to the republican and
two votes would go to the democrat
because
we're fairly evenly split
and
usually there's not a
significant third party or independent
candidate
hypothetical
strong third party or uh
independent candidate such as
ross perot or
john anderson or a few of the others
in this case candidates a b and c
getting
44 43 and 13 respectively
this formula gives
1.76 which rounds up to two votes
b at 43 percent gets 1.72 which rounds
up the two vote and c gets 13
or
at 13 gets 0.52 which rounds up to one
vote which adds up to five so
then the instruction on line 12
um
takes away the a vote from the second
highest vote getter
which then results in a having two votes
b having one vote and c having one vote
and in this particular case the
candidate who is almost tied for first
place loses a vote while the distant
the other
beginning on line 24 with if complaints
are filed attesting to voter fraud
i think that suggests that two or more
complaints would require the senate to
begin public hearings
and i
suggest two as a minimum since the word
complaints is pluralized
and it should be easy enough to get
two complaints in any election in the
state
seeing none thank you very much and and
also signed up to speak on 1324 is david
is that for all committee members
yes okay
you have to push it so that the red
shows in the microphone thank you thank
you madam chair members of the committee
i'm david scanlon secretary of state and
uh
alvin c just did a great job giving my
testimony
so
i am going to be very brief um right now
new hampshire's
four electoral votes are a prize
to whichever presidential candidate
happens to win new hampshire
in the general election
if house bill 1324 were to pass
unless a candidate won by a landslide in
new hampshire
but both candidates would effectively
both candidates of the major political
parties would effectively get the same
two
uh
electoral votes each
and if that were to happen there would
be really little incentive for a
candidate to come to new hampshire and
campaign here because
the outcome is
there there
could be an instance as alvin c
mentioned where there would be a strong
third party candidate
that could actually
you know by winning
13 14 15 percent
of the votes in new hampshire claim an
electoral vote
and actually take take that vote away
from
the second place candidate
who might have a very strong showing
um and you know i think you have to
question the fairness
of that
of that happening
um
what i passed around was simply uh an
example very similar to the one that
alvin c gave of uh
playing out the formula that is in the
statute
uh and you can see the same results
on this example that he gave in his
testimony
so i will stop there madam chair and i'd
be happy to answer any questions are
there any questions from
any committee members
representative muirhead representative
could i have the clipboard when you have
a chance
go ahead secretary scaling do you know
off the off the cuff in the back of the
envelope it looks to me like had this
been law in the election of 2000
um al gore would have been elected
president does that does that strike you
as
the right cap and accurate calculation
just kind of re-running you know what
maybe i should withdraw the question
just to avoid confusion i'm going to
withdraw the question thank you very
quickly
all right any further questions for
all right i'm seeing none thank you
secretary scanlon i have no one else
signed up to speak on this bill also uh
so
we have seven people who have signed up
against this bill and with that i'm
going to close the public hearing on 13
24.
yes
i've closed the public hearing okay
thank you
um
the next bill that we have noticed is
house bill 1359
relative to election day duties of
incumbent election officials
h.b
has to do with those election officials
who also appear on the ballot
you should also have distributed to you
an amendment that has been prepared by
the sponsor who is with us today to
introduce the bill representative rhodes
good morning madam chairman esteem
members of the election law committee i
am representative jennifer rhodes i
represent cheshire county district 15
which is winchester richmond marlborough
new hampshire being very unique
having
each town having its own government and
having such a large legislative body we
find that we have a great need for
several candidates and sometimes a very
small pool of people that wish to
perform those
history has shown that we have several
elected officials that often perform
more than one role
this bill was intended to solve the
concern
on election day to secure that everybody
is essentially following the same rules
our town moderator for i'm sorry our
school moderator for several years over
was also a state representative
he always would go out get a lawn chair
sit outside kind of mingle with
everybody else i thought that was the
law
so imagine my surprise
last year when i was running in five
towns
to find out the one of
my actual opponent
was actually a moderator and was inside
all day
then i was told that not only was he
inside all day but he was actually
escorting some people to the curtain
with phrases like let's make sure you
know who you're voting for today
now i recognize that that probably
doesn't happen with every single town or
school moderator but the fact of the
matter is everybody says that it doesn't
happen until it does
so
this has come to my attention that
there's been several bills over the
years that have been presented to
address this however none of them have
ever passed so that tells me that
obviously there is a concern
i also am not the only representative
that wrote
similar bills like this um
the reason mine is the one that you're
hearing today is because i was first
so um
my town clerk um
had a conversation with me over his
concern of the language and this was
before the bill was actually finished
and he explained that he's actually
elected to run the election and that
somebody does have to run the election
so before everything was finalized i
talked
with ols and asked him to please
exclude the clerk
because i heard his concerns
however
imagine my surprise when i found out
that new hampshire municipal association
had this bill as the number one bill of
the season to kill
so with that i had a conversation with
the new hampshire municipal association
and i do think that it was actually
a very productive one
so during our conversation we came to
the conclusion that really what i was
trying to say is if a person is in a
contested race
i believe that they should have to
follow the same rules as everybody else
i also was under
given a little bit of an education that
the moderators and i'm sure i will be
corrected if i am wrong
most of their duties do occur on the
your deliberative sessions and yes they
do perform work on election day i'm not
saying that they don't
however i also believe that we that you
are able to have backup moderators
you're also able to have volunteers so
after my discussion with the new
hampshire municipal association it came
to one of their biggest concerns was the
lack of volunteers
and i found it a really little bit
discouraging to think that something
that could potentially be a really good
piece of legislation
may be opposed because of lack of
volunteers when the fact is that the
moderators have never really had to get
a volunteer so we don't really know
right now that that is a problem
so we did come to what i believe is a
compromise and we do have an amendment
that you all have that basically says
that
if the con if the race is a contested
race
that is where basically everybody will
follow the same rules be outside behind
the line
however sitting here with mr graves um
he's actually now thinking that all
right
representative rhodes
mr graves can testify for himself okay
he's going to i know i know he's here
all right so we'll let nhma say what um
they're going to say thank you madam
chairman so um basically
where i was going from that was the
conversation we had i was going to ask
if you would let him please have that
conversation instead of asking me to
address that
um
and that is pretty much
i do believe that this is a happy
compromise for a solution to the problem
thank you representative does anybody
have any questions for representative
rhodes
thank you madam chair um
my question is regarding um selectmen
specifically elected in like the city of
manchester when their sole position is
to run the election
um
i understand the clerk the clerk
position but have you thought about also
removing the position of selectmen from
um
this bill because that's their only job
is to do that is to count votes
thank you for the question
representative
i think where a lot of the confusion
comes in is a lot of towns have
their own rules when it comes to
election day
our
our five selectmen if they are on the
ballot they actually do get volunteers
for the day and they don't work inside
the polls
all right just for clarification for so
everybody is aware um like
representative rhodes i come from a town
and we have selectmen um but cities also
have selectmen and they're only ju
they're elected by ward and truly their
only function
is to
run the election on election day there
are other staff who do other things so i
think that's what representative
alexander was referring to follow-up
representative alexander um thank you
madam chair that's exactly what i was
referring to that the the definition of
selectmen in a town like goffstown is
far different than the definition of
further questions there was one
representative bergeron thank you uh
representative
were you aware that part second article
32 of the new hampshire constitution
states that the moderator in the
presence of the selectmen and the clerk
shall conduct elections
and wouldn't it also be a second part of
that isn't your
bill therefore
possibly unconstitutional by trying to
restrict these elected officials from
performing the duties
given to them under our state
constitution
thank you for the question my my
intention is certainly not to go against
the new hampshire constitution i do
believe that we would all say that
there's been a lot of questions
surrounding election lately and what is
fair and what is not fair and i believe
that if you have a person that is on the
ballot and they're standing inside the
election the actual election place
and they're shaking hands with people
and introducing themselves when
everybody else is outside behind the
line i just don't think that that's an
equal playing field
thank you
representative lane did i see your hand
that was your question all right further
c9
representative hamer
would you believe in manchester alone
there would be at least 176
volunteer
elected positions
eliminated during an election in
manchester alone
thank you for the question i live in a
town that has four thousand people i do
not live in a city
so i do not know what takes place in the
city election
so
who would be running a follow-up
question a follow-up who would be
running manchester's elections if these
people are on the ballot
thank you for the follow-up question i
believe they you do have town clerks
you do have selectmen and you do have
moderators not every single person
576 of them are
in contested races yes
well i think it's it's very unfortunate
for the people that that are standing
outside if there's 176 people that are
inside working the ballot and also on it
representative barry
so i i i i share representative
bergeron's concern about article 30 can
you get a little closer to the mic i
don't know if you're getting picked up
i'm going to say that generally i'm sort
of having a hard time hearing people in
the room and i'm sure that people are
having a hard time picking up the
amplification so i i share
representative bergeron's concern about
article 32 because it says the election
shall be governed by the moderator um
but i think
we've we've talked about
the what i believe in this my question i
believe is the intent of your bill is
you don't want people
unfairly campaigning or receiving a leg
up that are also basically using their
position as an election worker to
get the last the last
pass out of voter if you will before
they go that's that's what you're trying
to get at right thank you representative
barry that that is exactly and i would
like to really stress to you all that
that there are town there are moderators
that i know for a fact that have sat out
of the election while they were also on
the ballot so if they were you know
running for state representative they're
also
the moderator they would set out that
election and i did talk to several
moderators and
several of them said to me well this
bill isn't necessary because so and so
already does sit out
and then i would explain that well not
further questions representative lane
so so i am from a city not from a town
so but
um
so are you saying that a moderator can
govern
without being physically present
so govern the the voting process and
govern the election without physically
being there
in the room
thank you for the question
when i had the discussion with the
moderators i spoke to they told me that
when they were not actually working in
the election that day that they had
somebody that replaced them either an
assistant moderator or they had another
volunteer for the day and they actually
are there they were just outside
further question
uh one other question as i read it i
noticed that
it's just selectmen inspector is there
any reason about is it any candidate so
like if i'm running on the ballot
could i volunteer as a poll worker
am i going to be prohibited from working
as a poll
to help my town because a lot of reps do
that
thank you for the question
and again in in my town in the towns
that i've spoken to if you are on the
actual ballot that day you are not
inside working on the at the polls and i
will say that's the case in my town and
most of the towns i know that if you're
on the ballot you are not working the
poll
so i never know whether people are
really being genuine when they tell me
not to run because they want me to work
the election or whether they just really
don't want to see me on the ballot
representative perez
thank you i i want to say i'm coming
from a town as well and then um
if you're on the ballot you're not
allowed to to volunteer as well right
further questions for representative
representative hamer sorry i did see you
before hi representative rhodes when you
said your moderator escorted people to
the voting booths
and they were talking
isn't that called electioneering
thank you for the question i do believe
that it is
so that shouldn't have been
thank you
you're absolutely correct that should
see none thank you thank you for your
time
also signed up to speak on this bill is
good morning everyone
thank you
i'm tina gilford i'm the town and school
moderator in derry
i'm really glad that someone brought up
the constitution
because
it is the moderator who governs an
election not a clerk
and this bill basically takes the
moderator's duties and tries to hand
them off to the clerk because the clerk
can be inside but the moderator can't
i do understand
that
no one wants electioneering to go on
and i do understand that not everyone is
me i get that because i don't do it
um
and i think anyone who is on the ballot
definitely cannot handle a marked ballot
should not be counting ballots
i have i have no problem with those
things
but there are other duties during the
day um so for example in derry
we have some we have what's called
they are people who have gone to court
and have a court order
to have their name hidden from the
checklist
those absentee ballots are to be
processed by the moderator and the clerk
i do not feel comfortable handing those
kind of duties to anyone
that's what i'm elected to do is to do
the job of the moderator
i've been in front of you recently
testifying that you know you want to
come after an elected official someone
who's put their name on the ballot and
be responsible for what goes on on
election day and i had no problem with
that
but you guys are now saying you know
this bill says so you're just going to
hand the whole process off to somebody
else
and you have to be outside
because the lower part of this bill
um
you know with the only the exception
who does not run the election
uh basically says unless you're casting
your own vote you're required to be
outside because the rsa that's
referenced
is the rsa that sets the no
electioneering in the preferred
electioneering zone outside
any member of the public can go to any
polling place on election day
and can go in and observe from the
public observation area
obviously except if
you know
this pertains to you because it sounds
i think people elect
their moderators their clerks their
supervisors of the checklist
to do their job
and while you can appoint someone to
assist
they don't know the ins and outs of rsa
they don't know how to quickly look them
up
trust me voters don't want to wait if
there's any kind of
issue
they want it handled they want to come
in they want to vote they want to leave
they want to be there less than 15
minutes um
i i do think
if there are people glad handing in a
polling place that to me would fall
under electioneering
and
that would be an issue that you know
bring it to the attention of the
attorney general there there are
electioneering laws already on the books
use them
um i i think that
most
most people are doing the right thing
but
the moderator is the one who runs the
election not the clerk and that's in our
constitution
thank you thank you questions
representative terezian thank you madam
chair thank you madam moderator for
taking the question
in your town does do you have an
assistant moderator and if so are there
an is it an elected position or
appointed it's appointed
and i have
about eight of them
follow-up thank you
so um
if
you couldn't be present whether
this legislation passed or for some
other reason
could could
one of those or a combination of some of
the assistants run the election in your
absence i would certainly hope so
i have a manual made up for them with
lots of things
they may run into something i don't know
but i you know it's not their job it's
mine
further questions
i'm seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this is
representative you
come on up
thank you madam chair and honorable
members of the committee um just for the
record it's it's pronounced off as soon
as i said i knew it was wrong but i
found you so that was it sorry i
apologize that's quite all right believe
me you don't you don't live this long
with that name and not have it
mispronounced once in a while
um
i just wanted to come in and i wanted to
uh support this bill
um i've heard the testimony prior and i
want to thank the committee for some
very very
uh insightful questions
i want to cut down to a little bit of an
anecdotal thing
in my town a friend of mine was running
uh for city council
and i was going to help him out and
stand with him outside
the polling place so we got to the
polling place and i see his opponent
standing outside
all nice and dressed up and everything
and then i see his opponent go inside
now
what
what struck me incredibly wrong about
this is my father
um
earlier
in the year or a couple years ago when
he went in to go and vote for me for
this position
he was turned away because he had a
but yet
this gentleman could stand inside
what better
advertising is there then while you're
inside
you know uh
it's an unfair advantage it shouldn't be
allowed
the problem with it is not
somebody doing their job elections come
along every couple of couple of years
every four years
excuse me
you can plan for this this is not a
really big deal
if you're worried about
any kind of election problems which
we've had or the perception of this
stuff the person who's running should
not be in the room that the election is
happening
go to a different ward go to i mean
there's got to be other remedies there's
got to be other things it's just not a
great look it doesn't serve anybody and
it casts doubt on our election process
so my uh my whole purpose here is just
to support this i like the amendment
i like the bill itself whichever way you
decided to go i would i would definitely
be in support of and if you have any
other questions i'd be happy to answer
as the best i can thank you
representative any questions
representative barry i have a question
of the chair have we received a copy of
the amendment
there was supposed to be one at your
desk and i i'm sorry i just haven't oh
thank you i haven't seen it thank you
i'm not seeing any thank you thank you
madam chair and thank you honorable
members of the committee have a
fantastic day
good morning members of the committee uh
dan healey
from
town clerk of derry representing the new
hampshire city and town clerks
association
we oppose this bill
most of our reasons were covered
by my town moderator tina gilford
i don't want to run an election without
our moderator she's the one
that knows
the
the most
about what's going on that day
we worked really well as a team and i
don't want her to be sitting outside not
even allowed in the building
on the day of the election just because
her name's on the ballot i believe
if anyone has concerns about someone
working the election and being on the
ballot if they've seen things
that's they can report them for
electioneering if they believe they're
doing something improper inside
i don't believe they should be banned
they're elected by the people in the
town or the city to do that job the
people in the town have the confidence
in them to do that job
and this bill making it so they can't do
what they are elected to do
is not something that we can support um
so i'd be open to any questions thank
you questions for mr healey
representative terozian thank you madam
chair thank you mr healey for taking the
question
do you
um
believe that the current law that
requires um candidates
just regular candidates not town clerks
or moderators
to
ensure that they don't election air or
or campaign
during election that they're required to
be in a separate spot away from the
voters do you think that is a good law
yes
follow-up
so help me understand how you reconcile
somebody that's on the ballot being able
to be inside of the guide rail in that
then
so for example our town moderator a town
water is elected by the people
of the town they put the confidence in
the town moderator to perform the job in
an unbiased way
in the current law now at the end of the
night when we're on the ballot we don't
handle the marked ballots
and i believe that's a good solution
we do our job throughout the day
and then at the end of the night
they're not near any any of the marked
ballots
i have a question mr haley is that not
handling of the ballots
your decision your moderator's decision
it's the marked ballots only so we can
pass out
um the blank ballots before
further questions
seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
natch grays
and representative taurosian if i could
have the clipboard this is the last
speaker i have signed up to speak on
1359.
thank you madam chair and nate grace for
the new hampshire municipal association
we do oppose the bill as written and
just to be clear we do oppose the
amendment although i do want to thank
the sponsor for being willing to work
with me
um to try to come to a compromise on the
amendment i think that's probably as
close as we were we're going to be able
to come
i certainly sympathize with the sponsor
and representative huff's concerns about
the last person
that a voter will see in the
uh in the polling place may also be a
candidate for office in a contested
election
um but we do oppose the the bill um and
we oppose it for the reasons you've
you've already heard today i don't want
to prolong this hearing so i'm happy to
answer any questions
questions
representative lane
thank you madam chairs so
putting aside the constitutional issue
could you
go through why you oppose it sorry to
make you do it but i would just really
like to know why the association opposes
it
sure so the uh
the election statutes are quite complex
and the role that everyone
everyone has in uh running the election
has been
very clearly defined and litigated over
the years
and of course
our major one of our major reasons is
that it's very hard to find volunteers
in a place like manchester you know
you're looking at replacing 172 i think
it was individuals
for the election
that's that's going to be very difficult
to find those people um we've certainly
heard
and
i can say from personal experience i
know that they're they're open positions
in in my warden have been for years
where i live
um and it's just incredibly difficult to
find people um and we certainly
understand the concern we want to make
sure that elections are are done with
integrity um
but it's uh we don't think that
um
there
that there is an issue here
further questions from committee members
representative teresian thank you madam
chair thank you sir for taking the
question
so
don't
don't you think we're sending a
potentially conflicting message to
voters that we say
for good reason
candidates
that are on the ballot can't be in that
position but if you're one of
the individuals in one of those
positions you can be isn't that
you know i think i think dealing with um
the issues of
uh
who voters are last to see in a
contested race is is a difficult um
policy choice um
it's it's one that uh
i mean the reality is
our state has so many elected positions
we already have a strong law against
electioneering that
it
i don't think it merits a change to the
law
thank you so as a follow-up
if you feel the electioneering laws are
strong enough then why not let everybody
um
well only the people who are election
officials are allowed to run the
election
unless i'm misunderstanding the question
well let me clarify if i may so
i heard your answer that
there's a we have electioneering laws so
that's sufficient for say a town clerk
or a town moderator that's that's inside
the guide rail if you will
so if you feel comfortable with that why
not allow other candidates be inside the
well because only the people running the
election are allowed inside the guard
rail to make sure that they're going to
run the election properly
further questions follow let me ask a
follow-up to representative derozan to
sort of
um
following up on what he said
why wouldn't we allow candidates to
stand inside the polling place outside
the guardrail because you're certainly
entitled to observe
as a resident of the community what goes
on you let the moderator know that's
what you're doing you go stand and you
watch so why wouldn't we why then are we
if there's a candidate inside the rails
why can't we have a candidate standing
well
i uh
i think that's a policy decision um for
the legislature
um
certainly it has been long-standing
tradition and we've seen that candidates
who are electioneering are
outside in the designated area
outside the polls um there is the
ability for the public to observe
presumably if a candidate didn't want to
uh you know wear paraphernalia that had
their name on it or slogan or anything
that would be barred by the
electioneering statutes presumably they
could go in and sit and watch the
election like any other member of the
public
seeing none thank you also signed up to
speak on this is
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members
um this is a really important bill for
me personally for the town that i live
in
uh there is current
currently some issues with regards to
how our elections were run in 2020
missing ballots absentee ballots
uh a number of other things
and there were some people in the
elected positions
that
i knew before this time and i witnessed
them inside because they've been running
for years and years and years and most
of the time unopposed they are inside
and they and they do cause because i
know them by face if they're the ones
checking off whether i'm whether i'm
how i'm voting like they're if they're
if they're standing on the exit and i'm
putting my machine in
and they tell me that i have to put it
in face up that's creating a chilling
effect on me because i know that's
what's gonna happen and i know that
that's gonna be my um my uh let's say
my um
town clerk is sitting there and she's on
the ballot
and she's at the exit
and she's gonna know if i left because
most the time in my town these folks are
running unopposed
not by choice but because our town does
not seem to want to have the
transparency that i'm hearing that um
even manchester seems to have and dairy
seems to have more transparency
we were not allowed as what we should
have been allowed but because we don't
because i did not know that the town
clerk is responsible for providing me
with everybody who is running for the
election in on march 8th
i did not know that that's public
information and that she had to give it
to me
so when i asked if certain people were
running unopposed because i felt
strongly that we needed if someone was
running unopposed i was going to run
against them because of integrity issues
that are currently being investigated by
based on that
i was not provided that information i
didn't know enough to turn around and
say it's a requirement you have to tell
me
so i am on the ballot but i'm on the
ballot for a position
that
i would have been on the ballot for a
different position had i known that one
of the persons that i personally have
integrity issues with is on the ballot
running unopposed um the bottom line is
is the way
i don't see a huge problem with
volunteers
the biggest issue for me is this is our
vote
i mean this is this is important and i
can't understand why an elected official
or or a candidate would want to be put
in that position where they may have
integrity issues or people believe that
they shouldn't be trusted
to this day i don't know if the people
that are being investigated by the
attorney general's office made mistakes
if there was something nefarious or if
it was even had anything to do with my
town officials
the bottom line is is that even in a
city like manchester she says is 176
volunteers just change wards they're so
close
i can tell you i witnessed i didn't even
know what electioneering was
but in 2020 i witnessed it in multiple
awards in manchester
um
and but i didn't know it at the time
because all i was doing was driving
folks to there and some of them were
elderly um or disabled so all i did was
drive them to their ward go in with them
and
basically give them the information
this is how you you know this is how you
go through the process um
i saw electioneering happening i saw it
happening so
i didn't know these elderly folks didn't
know
but they have the right for the they
have the right not to be silenced
they have the right not to be
manipulated
and this bill allows that it gives our
voters
integrity it gives our voters voters
understanding that
they are not going to be coerced or
manipulated it also in my opinion gives
our candidates
something to say there absolutely was
nothing bad going on because i wasn't
involved
thank you does anybody have any
representative hamer thank you for
176. volunteers in manchester were
assigned to our awards which we live in
we can't be going from ward to ward to
work
if you're going to be on the ballot
right what i'm saying is you have 176
volunteers
uh volunteers that go into the
go that are right now are currently
involved just
just switch the ward so so you so
you're
representative hamer i'm not sure it was
a question i i think and i'm doing a
little representative floor action did
you understand that in cities where
someone has volunteered to work an award
they must volunteer in the ward in which
they reside and may not be simply
flipped to other wards to work
regardless of how close they are
okay thank you further questions for
miss chester from the committee
representative for clarifying that for
me thank you i would i would just like
if you believe as i do
that most people who go to vote have
already made up their mind they knew who
the candidate is and they walked by the
excellent electioneering section with
their eyes focused which would be why
the moderator in goffstown has always
made us stand at the end of the driveway
where people can aim for us with their
cars not their hands
that is the last speaker i have on hb
representative terozian thank you
also signed up for this bill
were three people who did not speak and
they were in favor of the bill
i'm going to close the public hearing on
hb
1359 and open the public hearing
on
15 43
and with us is representative greeson a
sponsor to re introduce the bill welcome
representative
lisa i'm presuming that's why you're
here representative to introduce the
and i do have a number of people signed
up to speak on this so once we get
through the sponsor i probably am going
to ask witnesses to stick to three
minutes everybody indicated two or three
thank you welcome well thank you madam
chair and thank you members of the
committee uh this would be very short
i'm representative jeff greeson of
wentworth i represent grafton county
district 16.
my district is a floaterial that
overlaps with representative sanborns uh
she's here today but she's asked me if i
would uh speak on behalf of this bill to
introduce it uh we're both rookies so
i'm the one that uh she's gonna watch me
take all the flack and learn right but
house bill 1543 was written and
presented to us by a group of
constituents that we share who had a
desire to clarify the voter registration
process and establish a provisional
ballot process in order that we may have
more confidence in the integrity of our
elections it's the overall objective we
all want
specifically ensuring that only those
people who are legally allowed to vote
in new hampshire are registering and
subsequently voting in our elections and
that people are voting in the proper
places as well
i'm willing to answer any questions but
i believe that the better persons or
people uh to answer those questions the
specifics about it would be the actual
authors of the bill they wrote this and
presented this to us the amendment that
i just handed out to you is a very
simple amendment there's a misspelled
word uh if you would go to
uh page
five of the original bill and look at
line 34
the sentence reads uh that all motor
vehicles must being
their registration and it should be the
word begin
so the amendment just changes the word
being to begin
without changing the rest of the content
of the of the bill
line
34. so representative is there somebody
here who is going to go through the bill
yes ma'am they're they're here today
okay thank you
so given that who would the next speaker
for me to call would it be wise for me
to call
either one of these two gentlemen just
okay thanks just so everybody we can
follow along better
hold on
anybody else have any questions for
i'm not seeing any thank you thank you
see no flack it was a piece of cake
all right also signed up to speak on
this is edward
mcelroy if you want to come on up thank
you mcavoy
no
matt
if you i need somebody to come up to the
microphone come on up
and uh if
dave rivers could also accomplish
company names uh
also on the list should be there
okay i i'm gonna we would be better
prepared to answer any questions that
the committee might have
that's all right why don't we deal with
that if for purposes of presenting it
like sound looks like you're the one
with all the paperwork in front of you
um all right mr rivers if you want to
come up uh because it's um
a little unusual that i've got no
sponsor that apparently can speak to the
bill
um
though of course we earlier had a bill
that this we had no sponsor so
um we're trying to sort of do this as we
can
so
we have with us mr rivers yes
um welcome and
got it
all right and mr mcelroy if we could
recognize you in the first instance
please to speak to the bill thank you
right
president of campton new hampshire
the the reason for the bill and the
purpose is is that
our small towns
are getting
dominated
by people from away i call them people
from away they're coming into the and
they're just
registering to vote even though
i have many examples here from
our attorney general
we issued a
complaint against
individuals
and the attorney general just went ahead
and said no it's okay they can vote
there's a there's a case where a woman
from
away from massachusetts
registered to vote she registered a
vehicle in the town
then the
state's attorney general
after receiving our complaint questioned
her
she admits that she had a home in
massachusetts
where her husband
and family resided
she admits that she has a job
in massachusetts
as a schoolteacher
she admits that her children go to
school in massachusetts
she claimed
that she came
to new hampshire
to
practice remote
teaching
from her
place of
the
and said well you can vote then you're
you're up here you're doing remote she
abandoned and her children and her
husband down in massachusetts and decide
well i'm coming up here to live
the the problem is none of that happened
she just claimed that we know that
because we're our
neighbors anyways
moving on to the bill
we thought
that
rather than send complaint after
complaint
we thought that we could introduce
at the registration
a system of checks and balances
for example
in
in new hampshire once you register to
vote you're clearing you're declaring
yourself
domicile resident
once you do that
there are certain things that you have
to do the
motor vehicle laws in the state
require that you register your motor
vehicle and also
provide a license
all we're doing in the bill
balance between the two
also it introduces the checks and
balance on for example on page four
of the our introduce bill
on
line
it begins and continues on till 24.
it has it asks the people to if they
aren't
currently licensed will they get
licensed blah blah blah but the
before that but the what where what
we're saying is that they're telling
them that within 60 days they have to
get
licensed
and and register their vehicles
they
it also says
tells the clerk to follow up with the
department of motor vehicles
and they are to confirm that those
people now we are also introducing this
for provisional ballots
the provisional ballots are required
because it takes time to verify people
show up last minute within a few days
they can go down register to vote any
any time they want because our attorney
general has told them that they can do
that they can they can just say make up
any story that they want
and become a registered voter in the
state
it it
there's no checks and balances so we're
trying to make sure that the uh
registration creates those checks and
balances as it goes through
um
that's what i have to do have some more
thank you madam chair
and esteemed members of the committee
my name is dave rivers i live in
thornton a town next door to campton
a person i respect once said what you
need to vote in new hampshire is a new
hampshire state of mind
we think that's a little uh
an exaggeration but uh the the purpose
of what what it is that we're doing is
to tighten up our voter registration
process
in hopes of introducing clarity
and certainty where historically these
two characteristics have been missing
as evidenced by the
new hampshire state uh supreme court
uh declaring uh the
predecessor of the the bill prior to
this or the rsa prior to this is
unconstitutional
because the
uh wording was uh incomprehensible
so there's obviously a need and the need
has been confirmed by the new hampshire
supreme court uh briefly the goal is to
give everybody a ballot
make sure that they fill out the
registration form completely and
accurately
and again the issue of time is my
partner here ned has mentioned
uh if we have same-day registration in
high volumes
i've never worked this but i can see and
i've observed that it's somewhat chaotic
and the ability to verify
at that point in time
is
it's difficult so
our process is
come in
if we can't validate your registration
and we've completed a very thorough
completion of the form you can't
complete that to the satisfaction of the
people doing the checklist in the town
clerk
then we'll still give you a ballot you
could it would be a provisional ballot
you put an envelope seal the envelope
attach your uh application to it
and uh if we can verify
prior to accounting then so be it if we
can't then we'll put it aside and
depending on the majority
or the difference in the votes whether
these provisional ballots are necessary
to make a difference in the in the
outcome then they will be counted and
those that can't be verified have to be
put aside and held and not counted
that's essentially the
oh
thank you very much
back up we are back up all right
alvin
we don't need no yt
questions i think i was recognizing
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you
uh so a going back mr mcilroy to the
person in your community who
you say you don't think should be voting
there
she's a school teacher her children
attend school in massachusetts
and she
was working remotely at i guess it would
be a second property in campton right
okay
did she have her automobile registered
in new hampshire
yes
she also licensed in new hampshire
so uh
then in that case would she
be considered a resident under the
provisions of this
proposed bill here
that she would not even be a provisional
voter she would be able to vote just
fine
is that the case
one would uh need to get into a great
deal of more detail that perhaps would
be an invasion of privacy but
if one registers their car in new
hampshire you're going to pay an awful
lot less money than if you registered in
massachusetts and the checks and
balances to make sure that that person
was completely honest is somewhat
suspect so the answer to the question is
yes the car was registered but indeed
was it registered legally and all right
but notwithstanding let's stick to the
questions in the bill the question is
notwithstanding
whether or not the registration itself
was legal because trust me
election law is not getting into motor
vehicle registration legality we are not
um
no representative derozan please hold so
the question was
if under your bill
under this bill it's not your bill it's
two representatives under hb 1543 if
someone presents a new ham a valid new
hampshire motor vehicle registration
will will that
be proof of domicile slash residence the
change you've made in your bill
allowing them to be given a ballot
yes okay thank you all right
representative tarosian
thank you madam chair
just as a further clarification so if
this
proposed bill was law would that in any
i believe it would it could let me put
it that way no i think the answer that
the witnesses that the witness just gave
before that was that it would not that
what the witness just said is if you
present a valid motor vehicle
registration under this law you would be
entitled to use that as proof of
domicile and be able to vote we're not
getting into the legality or even
suggesting that our election law
officials
are someone to be questioning whether or
not a motor vehicle registration is
valid
representative hamer
thank you for taking my question um what
about a new voter who doesn't have a
vehicle
maybe they're disabled or they're
elderly
they're not going to have a vehicle to
register so part of this
amendment and law
would be
nil
thank you it would not apply to that
person if you are a driver or if you are
owner of an automobile but these are
really secondary issues
but our bill suggests that no tells you
that you need to follow the existing
rsas in the motor vehicle rsa section
uh and we think that that tightens
things up a little bit but yes you're
right if they didn't drive or they
didn't own a car then that would not
thank you further questions from
i'm seeing none thanks for coming and
thanks for going through the bill a bit
also signed up to speak on this is alvin
c and we are going to be doing three
minutes thank you
thank you madam chairman members of
committee uh my name's alvin c and i'm
from loudoun and i'm here to speak in
favor of the bill
i would like to point out and and this
is just a real quick thing on page 2
line
21 actions
in new hampshire that reveal your intent
to make new hampshire
you play
i think that should be your
include but are not limited to
and it gives several things but the one
on line 24 which says registering to
vote
i think should be stricken because it's
a circular argument if you're filling
out this form to register to vote
then
pardon me
then by by
usually it's just telemarketers but
anyhow registering to vote
by definition then becomes one of the
items that shows that you
make new hampshire your domicile so
i think that should be sticking out
that's all i really had on this
thank you questions for mr c
i'm not seeing anything
also signed up to speak on this bill is
hi
dan healy town clerk of derry
representing our new hampshire city and
town clerks association
we are opposed to this bill
um
going through the bill i'd like to point
out a few things
on page 4
it says the town clerk shall follow up
with the dmv to ensure applicant has
acquired a new hampshire driver's
license
after 60 days
i'm not sure how town clerks would do
that it doesn't provide any type of
procedure
i'm not sure the dmv is just going to
give us give out information like that
it doesn't say how we are to get that
information how the dmv is supplied to
us
if if town clerks are even
able to get that information
it
suggests does the applicant own any
motor vehicles subject to new hampshire
vehicle registration requirements
and also
ensure follow up with applicant to
verify new hampshire registration has
been completed
not all town and city clerks register
vehicles
so that's going to be a problem for the
clerks that don't
in derry our tax collector actually
handles the vehicles i don't have access
to any of the motor vehicle information
so it's telling the town clerk
to follow up to to see if they
registered a vehicle but i don't have
lines 21 through 20
the the main part of this is if the town
clerk or city declare determined such
registration to be complete and accurate
he or she shall sign the registration
form
the town clerk doesn't sign the voter
registration form that would be the
supervisor of the checklist they're the
ones responsible for approving or
denying a voter registration
so it's telling the town clerk now that
they're the ones that would approve or
or deny the registration on election day
and that's not really the town clerk's
job it's more of a supervisor function
and then our last concern
is on the same page page 8
lines 35-37
it's basically saying that if there's a
close race those provisional ballots
account within 24 hours
i don't know what more information we're
going to find out in the 24 hours that
we wouldn't have known the night before
so it's kind of a moot point to then
count them 24 hours later
we wouldn't really even have time to
verify any of the the other information
if we even could
so those are our association's concerns
with with this bill and i'd be open to
any questions thank you questions for mr
healey
seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this is
stanley bujalowski
i'm doing a terrible time with your
thank you
yes you want to press the button so that
you see a red light on the
just press yeah there you go perfect
okay
uh thank you madam chair and members of
the committee
uh i'd just like to uh voice my uh
approval of this bill and my support for
the
hb 1543.
most emphatically the provisional ballot
i'm in favor of and i'm quite surprised
that new hampshire hasn't established
this already particularly with the fact
that there's a same-day voting process
here in the state
and
as already has been mentioned
that process was is quite uh
hectic on the day of voting
could most likely arise uh questions
after
after the fact
and my understanding in new hampshire
and i'm i'm going to cite it off of a
senate bill 3 which i pulled off of
the state web page
correct me if i'm wrong i i'm assuming
that that for those these provisions are
still in effect in law
but
it states in that uh in that bill
and these these are guidance
identified as registering to vote in new
hampshire guidelines
in that provision it states regarding
regarding voting same day same day
voting
registration or shortly there before
it says if you do not have documents to
establish your qualifications please
bring them
if if you have documents to establish
your qualifications please bring them
when you register if you do not have
documents or forget to bring them it has
three bullets identifying the next steps
it states in bold capital letters you
will be able to register to vote
second bullet states you will be able to
vote and the third bullet states you
will use a regular election day ballot
that is counted on election day
if they're same day voting and those are
the established criteria
i cannot understand how a provisional
ballot cannot be at hand
because
after the fact which would be after
there may be found
with the registrant's
uh
facts and if if it's found that that
person was in
voted invalid
there's no way
to go back and correct the ballot that's
already been cast
a provisional ballot will not
prohibit someone from casting the ballot
but it will put in a proper procedure
that will allow for security
and a fair voting process
so for that the provisional ballot part
of this bill i think is is essential i
cannot understand how a fair and secure
election could be conducted
with those
rules that are already in place on
allowing same-day
registration or shortly before election
day registration with these provisions
without a provisional ballot
and with that that's uh conclusion my my
thoughts thank you thank you does
i'm not seeing any
thank you for coming
also signed up to speak on this bill is
may i pass out my
testimony
thanks
for the record my name is liz tentarelli
i live in newbury new hampshire and i
will first speak
personally representing only myself to
address the provisional ballot part of
this
people don't like provisional ballots
i wonder
what would happen to our first in the
nation primary status
if we were to use provisional ballots
candidates the press and the voters want
instant gratification we want those
results right away
i realize how important first in the
nation presidential primary status is to
many people
so i'd like you to think about that
related to provisional ballots
next i would like to speak representing
the league of women voters and i would
like to correct a statement from the
previous
person testifying that sb3 is in effect
it is not
that bill
is not in effect the new hampshire
supreme court ruled it unconstitutional
because it quote placed an undue burden
on the right to vote
and i believe that the first part of
this bill the registration process
tries to do exactly the same thing
so my written testimony gives a number
of
reasons and specifics and i thank alvin
c for pointing out the circular logic on
page two
that's in my testimony as well
and in fact a lot of this is circular
logic and confusing to potential voters
if people try to vote fraudulently they
should be prosecuted
but for the huge majority of people who
want to register
want to participate in our government
this is an undue complication it is not
necessary
and i do point out that the state paid
over four million dollars and hundreds
of hours of staff time to fight sb3
and while this is not worded the same as
sb3 the confusing status
the attempt to suppress voting uh is is
the same intent
and i don't think we want to go through
that again
so i thank you for this opportunity to
speak both as an individual and
representing league of women voters and
if there are any questions i'd be glad
to address them any questions from
committee members
seeing none thank you thank you also
signed up to speak on this bill is
thank you very much madam chair
i'm
mostly here to introduce the next bill
but i figured i need to chime in on this
one in opposition there's a couple of uh
couple of points in particular one as
we're going on about the
driver's license and the driver
registration those are of course not
requirements to vote but also
moreover
having a the wrong address on your
driver's license or having a incorrect
motor vehicle registration is it's not a
felony so it doesn't
disqualify you from voting it doesn't
take away any of your other civil rights
you know it's just a minor motor vehicle
uh
violation so uh
normally
normally for violations of that uh
magnitude in other areas nobody would
say that you should lose your right to
vote over those um also especially with
driver's licenses
we have a reciprocal agreement with
every other state in the union and uh
also all the canadian provinces and
i'm by no means an expert on either but
basically
for the purpose of identification the
purpose of proving your authorized to
drive any state's driver's license is as
good as any other
so that's
true even when you're registering to
vote you do need another document to
prove your uh your
your citizenship and your address but
that's a sufficient proof of who you are
and there are
um
there are other uh there are like other
uh
other things there are other things you
can show in addition to driver's license
prove your identity like your uh armed
forces id or your which uh also are not
necessarily
tied just to this address where you are
currently and also
the provisional ballots um it's very
very
complicated or like we're having enough
trouble uh you know it's we should keep
our elections as simple as possible and
um
that also if we have a close election um
that'll create a lot of doubt about the
validity of the uh results we certainly
almost had uh
we nearly had a very tragic situation
nationwide with the 2020 presidential
election i know there's a wide
range of opinions about that but
i'm sure everybody agrees that uh
that at least the losing candidate had
pretty severe doubts about the validity
of the election and that uh kind of
complicated the peaceful transfer of
power although it did happen and that
could happen on a statewide level
senator
i'm going to insist at this point that
you speak
to the bill okay i was speaking about
just showing his example why provisional
ballots are over complication and a bad
idea um so that's um
[Music]
such basically those two issues and also
just historically going back in the
history uh back in you know
the uh 19th 18th century you didn't need
to own a horse or register your horse
and even today you know you don't need
to own a car to drive there are at least
you don't even need to be registered
don't even have a driver's license i
know there are at least three members of
this legislature who do not have
driver's licenses because they cannot
physically cannot drive and you know
there's
other reasons why people
you know so you don't need to have a
driver's license to vote although it's
certainly a good thing to happen
and also it's a good thing to people
again if you can wrap it up okay that's
about what i had
had to say that it's uh
you know that this is just a necessary
complication and um so i just thought
i'd bring up try to bring up those
points before i went and introduced my
bill which those issues may come up in
that one too so thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill as
hi thank you madam chair i'm the
committee for taking my testimony my
name is louise spencer i'm from concord
new hampshire
i'm co-founder of the kent street
coalition which is an all volunteer
grassroots advocacy organization
but i speak today here on my own behalf
i
find this bill to be
beyond
disturbing
i have to say
the idea that we would create
two classes of voters some of which are
essentially
being deemed as second-class
citizens who
are
having to use a different ballot who are
having to vote in a different booth
or could potentially
lead people to
interpret them as being somehow less
worthy of voting or cast suspicion on
their right to vote
is beyond offensive in a democracy
it is not the way we've done things here
in new hampshire it certainly is not the
way i hope that we do things
in the future
also
being from away is not a
disqualification for voting in new
hampshire
we are encouraging people to move to
this state
we need people to move to this state
especially young people
and this idea that
somebody can be questioned in whether
they belong to a particular town or they
don't belong
is problematic particularly in the
instance cited
where in fact the person appeared to
have met the requirements for voting
it was reviewed by the ag and yet her
right to vote was still being questioned
i find that
and as someone who was involved with the
um
sb3 lawsuit which dragged on for a long
three years at great expense
of time and effort
i certainly would hope that we would not
go down a bill which clearly burdens the
right to vote in many of the same ways
that
the court found that sb3
burden the right to the fundamental
right to vote
and i do want to also end with
underscoring that point the right to
vote is a right it is not a privilege
it is a right
and any law
that is
being looked at
to impact that
that right that fundamental
constitutional right
both under u.s and state constitution
needs to be tread people need to tread
very very carefully
so as not to
upend
that essential right of democracy so
with that i will end my testimony thank
you does anybody have any questions for
i'm seeing none thank you thank you so
much
also signed up to speak on this bill is
kate gargano from the secretary of
and representative taurosian if you
could get the clipboard for me when you
have a chance this is my last pink card
welcome
hello again
for the record my name is katie gargano
and i'm representing the secretary of
state's office i'm speaking on behalf of
house bill 1543 for informational
purposes only and i'd like to raise a
few concerns that we found within the
bill
the bill brings many changes to our
existing voter registration form
on page 1 line 11 states that the form
shall be no larger than eight and a half
by 11 inches
but the next almost five pages of the
bill are items that must appear on the
form so
that may need some work
the information that's requested
has many duplicates there's as an
example there
are asking for the voter's name and
address multiple times throughout the
bill
and it would uh this would increase wait
times at the polls and longer lines that
the supervisors of the checklist table
if voters had to fill out a form as it's
presented
i won't be speaking about the
provisional balance section because
there's already been multiple bills out
there that you've heard
any questions
that is the last speaker that i had
signed up for
this bill
with an amendment that's been presented
to the committee
today we also had people here
president this morning who's who signed
up in regards to the bill
and in regards to people who did not
speak we have one person who has signed
up against the bill
and four people who have signed up in
favor of the bill so with that i'm going
to close the public hearing on
and open the public hearing on hb
1203 and with us today to introduce the
bill is representative horgan welcome
back this morning
thank you very much i continue to be and
i think maybe i forgot to say so a
minute ago that i'm representative
timothy horrigan from stratfor county
district six the towns of durham and
madbury
durham is not coincidentally the home of
the university
of new hampshire um
and uh
i apologize i don't have written
testimony on this bill i uh my
scheduler
somehow had the idea that this hearing
was on march 10th and it was february
10th and i i've i've
i've
i've discussed that extensively with
that member of my staff and uh he's very
sorry for the mistake he made but but
i'm here and i do from what i wrote last
year about fb
hb 538 and i hope it's okay to
acknowledge at least that uh both the
well actually all through the 2020
legislative session the 2020 legislative
session and this one all took place
under unique circumstances so we kind of
did things
differently than we did
we would have otherwise and you know
we're doing the best we can and um
and the committee this hb 1203 was a
basically an identical bill aside from
the dates which went before this
committee and um
you did decide to find it inexpedient to
legislate and normally that would have
been the end of the story except it
never made it to the floor of the house
it wasn't even tabled so you know the
rules allow me to bring it back so here
i am again and um if you
representative horrigan i just missed it
can you give me the number from the
first year again oh this is uh virtually
identical to uh hb i'm sorry i may have
hp 538 is i may have said hb 1203 which
is the bill i'm talking about right okay
and um so we we
we had a hearing on it last year and um
you know it did come out of the
committee itl 11 to 9 which i'm i'm
going to guess that that's the same as
the number of members of that time from
each party but i don't remember don't
know who exactly who voted how but
um
that was then this was now and then
hp 538 in terms of combination two bills
which i sponsored in 2019 which actually
uh passed the house and senate before
being vetoed by the uh by the governor
and um
and even under the
free pandemic rules the way we did
things veto bills can be reintroduced
next year so i decided to introduce
those two bills and the uh
that time they were actually tabled so
like the governor never got it they
never even made it to to the senate but
um
and this so
it's it's um there's it it's a lot more
complicated than looks i'm basically
just overturning three bills um
sb3 which was in 2017 you heard a lot
about there's an early one sp 318 which
covered some of the same ground as sp3
and then hp
1264. and um
so the
part about sp3 makes up the first 15
sections of the 17 section bill and i'm
sure you've all read it and memorized it
or probably not but um
so the first thing it does is just as i
said the first thing the sb3 uh
forms which actually are the laws not
currently being enforced because it was
uh challenged in federal court but just
just greatly complicated and made the uh
made the forms a lot more duplicative
put a lot of pretty scary language so
it's intimidating the voters and it was
also written at a phd level of reading
of a reading comprehension and um i we
actually my town actually does have a
few phds living there but i think even
they found them i mean they filled out
the forms they plowed through it i've
watched uh
i watched unh students some of whom were
undergraduates and graduates alike and
they all managed to fill out the forms
but it was just unnecessarily cumbersome
it's like they were trying to take out a
mortgage or something so that's
and there's also
two things about residency so they added
uh
they added the phrase for the indefinite
future uh
there they actually took it out of the
law and i'm trying to put it back in
either way it's kind of a
meaningless phrase because
everybody's future is indefinite but it
did seem at least be interpreted by
someone's attempt to prevent uh students
and other people who are
transient to move around a lot from
voting in new hampshire and that's uh
for sure that's unconstitutional there's
uh
several
federal court cases including the famous
neuberger course which was a dartmouth
student who uh
basically his parents were dead and he
lived in hawaii so he had no residence
other than than hanover but
he wasn't sure where you live in hanover
there's also like the
sims decision in texas which had to do
with a uh historically black college
that was located in uh you know as a
suburb of houston and there's a conflict
you know with the county
elections commission specifically
guaranteed
college students the right to vote on
their at their college addresses because
i know there's a lot of talk about
residents permanent residents blah blah
blah but um
college students like are not um
are residents of the place where they're
living most of the year
and they are entitled to claim that as
their domicile and there's really no
good way in law to distinguish them from
other people who move there for other
reasons you know they all
pay rent they pay taxes they hold jobs
they do everything else everybody else
does in new hampshire and
any attempt to
disenfranchise them aside from being a
bad idea and unconstitutional it's going
to take in a lot of other people who
you're not trying to get you know who
aren't students you're not trying to uh
and um
it's just essentially uh essentially
unfair and unwise for many reasons also
if you actually
did manage to come up with some formula
that somehow would exclude students for
citizens of new hampshire but
allow everybody else who's moved there
relatively recently a long time ago
you're going to probably create a class
of people who
can't vote anywhere and i don't think
anybody wants that
has been represented
well they can just vote absentee back
home but absentee voting is you know
they often attach the adverb simply to
it and synthetic voting is not simple
and um
it's getting more complicated there's no
guarantee
yeah there's no guarantee that uh you
know someone who's a student at one of
our colleges universities could simply
vote absentee back home they may not
meet the requirements there but they
certainly are residents at the place
where they're living when they're going
to college and that also is by the way
where the census counts them so the uh
i'm we're still working under the uh
2010 census but the 16 000 or so uh
inhabitants of my district who are
enumerated in
in 2010 included uh included all the
students who were living on campus or on
off-campus student-oriented residences
and
the same was also true with the 2020
census as uh which many of you have been
on the registration committee so that's
basically basically my bill just changes
a couple of uh
unwise changes to the law back it's a
lot simpler than it looked as many pages
long and um
i apologize for not having written
testimony just on this bill i had a
little
there's a little bit of a
as i said my scheduler screwed it up and
then
we also then
i then also like the technology down in
the new uh
work area down where the smoking areas
it's they still haven't got all the bugs
worked out of it so even though i knew
in principle how to
copy and paste and
make a new set of testimony for this
bill uh just take what i did in march
2021 and adapt it to now but i was just
not able to do it in time so
thank you representative
happy to take any questions you can of
course email that to us oh yeah i'll try
to yes
any questions from committee members for
representative horgan
i'm not seeing any thank you all right
thank you
um the last person i have signed to
speak up on this is david scanlon
secretary of state so when somebody has
a chance to grab the clipboard that
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm david scanlon secretary of
state
and i i have been on the opposing side
of this particular issue
with my good friend representative
horrigan
for some years now but there is
something in this bill that i can agree
on with him and i'll get to that in a
minute um
the um
there's a history with this bill related
to the definition of domicile and
residency
and
at the
beginning of the century you know in the
2000s there were some statutory changes
and some court rulings
that that
created a fuzzy definition of just what
domicile in new hampshire meant
especially for the purposes of voting
and that created a situation where we
were unique among the 50 states
um
and
it was that the laws were such that
a person that would otherwise be
considered transient
not a not a resident of the state but
somebody just passing through
for a period of time could register and
vote here
and so more recently the laws have
changed and we had an advisory
opinion from the supreme court
that said that domicile and residency
are now effectively the same thing and
they should be
and that puts us in alignment with the
other 49 states in that regard
this has nothing to do with college
students it just simply has to do with
a single standard on what residency and
domicile means
in new hampshire
as long as a college student considers
new hampshire their residents and they
agree to abide by the same laws as any
other state
then they're fully entitled to vote here
just like any other resident
if they're not willing to
take those steps and make that
commitment then they should be voting
from the place that they came from as an
absentee voter and it's that basic
other states in their statutes you know
apply uh
some exemptions for students and i won't
go into all of those but
um
you know our neighboring states treat
college students differently outside of
the single stat standard that you have
to be a resident
um
so you know i i believe that the
statutes in terms of the definition of
residency and domicile are where they
should be
and uh and we should leave it alone the
one area in the bill that does need some
work is that as has been mentioned
the state lost the lawsuit uh on the
enactment of senate bill 3.
that language that we cannot enforce or
administer is
uh in some significant portions of our
statute
uh it's confusing and you heard
testimony on another bill from a couple
of gentlemen that were
talking about that language as if it was
the statute
it isn't a statute but it's not
enforceable so to make our statutes
clear we probably should take a look at
uh
at cleaning that up so
the language reads uh
um
along those lines i you know i've i've
heard the the the uh
the amount of money thrown out there
that the state spent four million
dollars on defending
that lawsuit
which when a suit is made has to be
defended
of that four million dollars
around a million dollars was spent by
the state
with its expert witnesses and the
attorneys that were used on the case
over three million of that was having to
pay the plaintiffs attorney fees and so
that's how much the other side spent uh
arguing that case
and it's standard that when the state
loses they pay those fees
i will also add that when senate bill 3
was
using those statutes and that election
ran very very smoothly and it was after
that
that the court uh made their ruling that
it was uh unconstitutional based on
whatever reasoning it was that uh
that they felt was appropriate so with
that i'd be happy to answer any
questions questions from committee
members
it's always good to be the speaker at
lunchtime
any questions
seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up today here in regards to
registering an opinion on hb 1203
we have six people who signed up who did
not speak three in favor and three
against
and with that i'm going to close the
public hearing on hb 1203 this committee
is in lunch recess we will be back here
at one o'clock
to
have executive session on the listed
everybody that we are essentially live
streamed from the morning when it goes
on do they put a sign up when we're in
recess christina they do all right so we
are back
it is a little after one o'clock
it this is the house election law
committee today is february 10th
we have a number of bills scheduled for
executive sessions starting at 1pm
so with that
we are going to start with and go
through them as listed the first one is
cacr17
this is relating to ballot measures and
it provides that upon petition by voters
uh yes madam chairman i move that cacr
17 be inexpedient to legislate
uh very briefly madam chairman as i said
during the hearing new hampshire elects
its state government every two years
we're one of the very few states that
change out every facet of state
government every two years
by such
and given that we have such small state
representative districts we are already
incredibly responsive to the people and
that this i view this as unnecessary
given our current form of government
is there any further discussion on this
representative bergeron um i also will
support the motion i
you know here in new hampshire every
bill gets a hearing and a vote and i
think we had a good experience this
morning that shows it's not that hard to
get a bill before the committee to to be
considered
i think our legislative body is very
responsive to our constituents and if
they want a bill put before us we we do
it for them and so i will also
vote to find this in expedient to
legislate
further discussion
i want to say that this is an issue that
is not new
for legislation to be brought before the
legislature um whether there is a direct
petition or relating to a referendum
power of citizens um this is sort of a
session reoccurrence not to diminish its
importance
um and i will just note
that
in my review of notes i actually ended
up pulling up
cacr17
on
statewide referendum powers only it was
from
two sessions ago
so
it comes up so often we actually
randomly can get the same number
assigned to it
i also want to say and i don't know that
this really came up my concern about
this bill
and this process and i understand the
desire for it
is that new hampshire is very local we
have local elections i like to think um
that that as a people we have very local
control over what happens even up to the
state government and i think that this
type
of an ability the ability to do this
type of thing
um would encourage out of state money
issues
directly by virtue of the power of the
dollar as compared through legislation
which is i view much more the power of
the people so um i
v i understand the need for this but
in a state governed the way it is i am
not sure it is appropriate
anything else before i call the vote
seeing none i'm going to ask
representative hayward to call the vote
representative mcdonald yes
prudhomme o'brien
yes
representative sweeney yes
clerk says yes representative tarosian
yes
representative berry
representative groan yes representative
quailey yes
representative alexander yes
representative wilhelm
yes
representative
bergeron yes
representative ward yes
representative perez
yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane
yes no oh god yes sorry
representative freitas
yes
representative hamlet yes
representative muirhead yes
madam chair yes
the vote is 20 to 0.
if there is no objection that will go on
the consent calendar i'm seeing none so
we will mark that for the consent
the next bill we have scheduled for
executive session is hb 1008
establishing a commission to study the
structure and election calendar of new
hampshire municipal government
um is there a motion
representative barry yes madam chairman
i move that hb one zero zero eight be
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second
madam chair i'll second that
would you like to speak to your motion
uh very briefly madam chairman um it's
not the right time for this legislation
it should be something that we should
consider in the future um you know
sometimes these sponsors can get a
little off the wall but i think it's
representative wilhelm
i just want to echo that uh sometimes
the sponsors can be a little off the
wall
so i will also be both uh i'm putting
itl
[Laughter]
um
i want to thank the the persons who
moved this and seconded this um
i when i looked at this bill i pondered
in
the second year of the session going
into elections where we would find three
members of the senate governor and
secretary of state that would be willing
to to serve on this
um and
i think that
underlying this there might be a
question about whether
allowing elections to be held all at the
same time of year instead of going
through what we're going through now
which is elections in march
might be something that would be
interesting to look at
um
but i agree that
this is probably not appropriate at this
point in time
any further discussion yeah
fortunately there are not minutes taken
of executive session
all right i'm going to ask the clerk to
call the role
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yeah
clark
clark says yes representative tarosian
yes
representative berry a resounding yes
representative growing yes
representative quailey yes
representative los alas
yes
representative alexander yes
representative bergeron yes
representative wilhelm
representative ward yes
representative perez
yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane yes representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes
representative muirhead
yes
madam chair
vote is 20 to nothing the vote is 20 to
not to zero
with no objection that will go on the
consent calendar and for people who who
may be watching um i want to thank
representative sweeney who participated
in the motion and voted it was if you're
not watching you if you're watching you
don't know this the bill we just
essentially
said go away to was a bill proposed by
him
so
hence the little joviality here we were
not trying to be disrespectful to
anybody
well maybe some people were trying to be
disrespectful
all right the next bill we have
scheduled for executive session is hb
1082.
this is a bill prohibiting certain state
officers from forming political action
committees is there a motion
yes representative
o'brien yes madam chair i move ought to
pass on 1082 and is there a second
representative alexander seconds it
would you like to speak to your motion
yes thank you
there are three states
tennessee maine and new hampshire where
these
constitutional officers are selected by
the legislature
and the experience in maine where i
spoke to
bruce peliquin he's you probably all
know him as the former congressman from
maine but prior to that he was
he was the treasurer of maine and then
prior to that he was in the financial
services business spoke to the treasurer
of maine
a man named mr shapiro um
this was many this is back in the early
80s and mr shapiro had a pack
and was
requesting money for that pack
and
he mr peliquin was quite surprised about
that because of the conflict of interest
and not long after that the um the
legislature in maine passed a bill very
similar to the one that we uh have here
today in front of us and for that reason
um i believe that this should be uh this
should this this should pass and
i'd be voting yes on ought to pass
thank you representative o'brien anyone
else uh wish to comment on this
motion mr westchester yes
thank you representative mcdonald
i'll be voting against the uh the motion
of vote to pass we took this up uh
i think most recently in 2019
and um at that time it was pointed out
that the right to participate in
democracy through political
contributions has been protected by the
first amendment and that was the supreme
court's ruling in buckley versus vallejo
so in addition to to acknowledging that
we do have a first amendment right to
raise funds for campaign purposes i
would just note that the way the
legislation is written
it may prohibit the candidate from
forming a political committee but that
doesn't say that no one else can do it
on their behalf
and then just donate the funds to the
person running for that office so
i don't see where the legislation would
be effective and i also believe it
would not stand up to a constitutional
challenge
further discussion
o'brien thank you i just want to add to
that not exactly um in response to mr
bergeron's but there was a few other
things i wanted to add uh that the state
of tennessee uh the secretary of state
in tennessee that i spoke to back when i
first
introduced this bill a few years ago
said the uh the state the state
legislature in tennessee would would
write him out on you know on
out of town if he tried to
create a political action committee in
running for secretary of state
just a smaller legislature maybe
education among the the members is is a
little
different the way that that goes they
have fewer newcomers each year for
example
so
that was one of the concerns in addition
there's a whole month two months month
and a half or so between when people are
elected in new hampshire and when we
have to
select the secretary of state that gives
the secretary of state candidates or
people that are interested in that
position enough time to contact each and
every one of us even though there are a
lot of us that they do have the option
to do that so
just wanted to add that as well thank
you
further discussion the bill under
discussion for vote is hb 1082 the
i'm seeing none i'm going to ask the
clerk to call the roll
representative mcdonald yes
yes
representative sweeney yes
clark says yes
representation yes
representative barry
yes representative groan yes
representative quailey yes
representative los alas
yes
representative wilhelm no
representative ward no
representative perez
no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas no
representative hamlet no
representative
no
yes
all right hb 1082 will be reported out
of committee as otp i'm assuming there
will be a majority and a minority report
on that
the next bill we have scheduled for
executive session today
one hb
nine is relative to the number of names
required for nomination by nomination
papers
is there a motion on hb 1149
representative
growing
and is there a second yes ma'am chair
representative alexander seconds it
representative growing would you like to
this bill reduces by two-thirds the
threshold for filing nomination papers
for
various elected positions in new
hampshire
we heard testimony that this would
very likely crowd the ballots make it
make the ballots more
difficult to
to understand
and i can particularly understand that
in races like
president united states senator governor
where under this bill only a thousand
registered voters would be required for
those nomination papers
i think that the current threshold that
we have in law are adequate and they
should remain
is there any further discussion on hb
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien
yes representative sweeney yes clark
says yes representation yes
representative barry yes
representative growing
yes
representative quailey yes
representative los alas
yes
representative alexander yes
representative bergeron yes
representative wilhelm
representative ward yes
representative perez
yes
representative hamer yes
representative freitas
yes
representative hamlet yes
representative muirhead
yes madam chair
yes
the vote is twenty zero to recommend
that hb one one forty nine be found
inexpedient to legislate without
objection that will go on the consent
calendar
the next bill that we have is hb 1174
relative to election challengers you
have all been pat given an amendment
is there a motion in regards to the
amendment representative mcdonald
yes madam chairman i move this amendment
ought to pass
is there a second
representative sweeney seconds it
um would you like to speak to the motion
or would you rather have me speak to it
since
i did it
madam chairman you can be much more
eloquent than i can so i'll defer to you
thank you
um
the committee might recall that the the
sponsor of this talked about how it was
very simple and clarified just as to
where the location of the challengers
was as is often the case when i look at
a bill
what one party thinks is simple and
clarifies i think might cloud the issue
so i had a discussion with the sponsor
and i wanted to clarify two things
because i felt the bill as written did
not do it
um one was in regards to
being close to the location where
ballots are hand counted and ballots are
hand counted or
for a number of reasons one is for
tabulation
and one is to count the number of
ballots
and those occur at two
different times or places in a polling
place i know in my polling place when we
are going through the ballot set of each
machine at the end of the night we have
round tables set up in a number of
locations in the gymnasium and there
would really be no effective way of
putting anybody within six feet of those
tables because we have a number of
tables um going through just counting
the physical ballot as compared to
uh ballots that are rejected by the
machine
over voted ballots which are being
looked at by
workers at the polls which is a
different exercise than counting so i
spoke to the sponsor to clarify what his
intent was and the intent was to be able
to watch
where a completed ballot is being
interpreted by an election worker for
the purposes of counting
so i asked ols to make a change to that
so i had them change the language to
provide that it would be for the hand
counting of ballots for the tabulation
of votes
because at the end of the night when
we're counting our piles of 25 and cross
changing them i don't know that anybody
really cares about viewing that
the second thing was the regards to the
line of sight for an electronic ballot
counting device um
i didn't um oh excuse me in the the
second part of that was the language
was uh within
stand within six feet
and i just was uncomfortable with that
language and i asked them to change the
language of not more than six feet um
because i didn't want people to be able
to say i want to be a foot within six
feet i wanted to have the limit that the
and
those were the two changes that were
made i didn't really think that there
was an issue in regards to maintaining a
lighter line of sight on the actual
ballot counting machines
that seems pretty straightforward
and there's no requirement in my opinion
to be close to that to see that they're
operating or who's
using them just approaching it
so that those were the reasons that you
have an amendment before you
questions or discussion question
representative bergeron thank you madam
chair um just for clarification
you said the intent of the amendment is
to
uh
just allow for the watching or the close
viewing of the actual counting of the
ballots
um so one of the diverters have been
removed from the accuvope machines in
most towns and cities and so now
election officials have to physically
sort through all those ballots to find
any with write-ins
that work wouldn't necessarily have to
be within six feet of observers that
would be my position that's why i
specifically tied it to tabulating votes
representative hamlet
thank you madam chair so
does this mean that the moderator could
set a limit of
four feet they can't
right does it he couldn't set a limit of
eight feet
he couldn't set eight feet but anything
up
six feet but if if he said it at six
feet
i think the other one it would have been
five you know five eleven there there
could have been at least a discussion
about no i wanna be closer i i wanted to
make it clear that it was something that
could be set within the six feet
and
it would be what it was going to be
right so for the question sure so
so the um
if the challenger said i i want i need
to stand one foot away so i can see
the moderator has the option to go up to
six feet yeah
okay
further questions
i have to tell you 20 years ago i
probably would have thought six feet was
way too close but as i get older i think
any further discussion on the amendment
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role on the amendment
yes
representative sweeney
clerk says yes representation
yes representative berry yes
representative growing yes
representative quailey yes
representative los alas yes
representative bergeron yes
representative wilhelm
yes
representative ward
representative perez
yes
representative hamer yes
representative lane
yes
representative freitas
representative hamlet yes
representative muirhead yes
madam chair yes
vote is 20 to 0.
thank you hb 1174 now stands in the on
the floor as amended amendment 2022 649.
is there a motion on
the
current motion excuse me on the current
item before the board representative
growing
yes madam chair i move out to pass on
1174 as amended
is there a second
representative alexander seconds did you
want to speak to your motion
representative growing yes i do uh for
reasons as eloquently stated by our
chair uh
i
believe that this is a good amendment it
clarifies uh the intent of the bill and
the bill now as as amended will help to
add
clarity to our election processes
any further discussion on the motion on
the floor which is house bill 1174 otp
as amended
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll up sorry
oh representative ward thank you thank
you madam chair i just wanted to
make sure in my own mind that this
refers only to the appointed challengers
not members of the general public
correct i believe challengers has a
legal definition and that's what we're
talking about okay i wasn't sure some of
the witnesses knew that
all right i'll ask seeing nothing else
i'll call have the clerk call the roll
thank you
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes buck says yes
representative rosian yes
representative barry yes representative
growing yes representative quali yes
representative los ellis yes
representative alexander yes
representative bergeron yes
representative wilhelm yes
representative ward
yes
representative perez
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes representative
murrehead yes
i'm chair
yes
the vote is 20-0 thank you
the vote is 20-0 without objection that
will go on the consent calendar
the next item
noticed for vote this afternoon
is
hb 1197 relative to the definition
of party for election purposes
do
i have a motion representative sweeney
madam chair i move we find house bill
1197 and expedient to legislate is there
a second i second the motion
representative terozian seconds it would
you like to speak to your motion
representative sweeney uh yes thank you
madam chair very briefly uh this bill
would change the threshold for
party access to the ballot uh from four
or party recognition in the state of new
hampshire excuse me from the current
four percent threshold in the preceding
statewide election
to just one percent in the preceding
we have a fairly simple system in new
hampshire for third party candidates to
get on the ballot to prove with
signature petitions that they can
currently get on the ballot and if a
third party candidate does not meet the
sufficient signature requirements we
then go a step further and allow for
write-in candidacies for any office on
the ballot
if someone were so motivated to organize
their campaign that way
in recent years we've seen a third party
achieve
party recognition status in the save new
hampshire in 2016 the libertarian party
had more than four percent in the
gubernatorial election
and they gained party recognition status
uh but they were not able to maintain it
and they lost it after the 2018
elections
so i think currently our our laws on
party recognition are fair uh and this
proposal and any of the amendments that
were associated with this bill do not
need to go into effect at this point
thank you
is there any further discussion on hb
representative bergeron thank you i
agree with representative sweeney
and i would just add though while there
are some who might feel that the four
percent is a high threshold uh the one
percent that's proposed in this
legislation is by all means much too low
and therefore i'll support the emotion
i got to figure out when we don't need
all right
if there's no further discussion i'm
going to ask the clerk to call the rule
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes clark says
yes representation yes
representative berry yes representative
growing yes representative quailey yes
representative los ellis yes
representative alexander yes
representative bergeron yes
representative wilhelm
yes representative ward yes
representative perez
yes representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes
representative muirhead yes madam chair
yes
the vote is 20 0.
the vote
on hb 1197 is to recommend itl with no
objection that will go on the consent
calendar
the next item scheduled for executive
session this afternoon is hb 1252 this
is relative to political contributions
made by certain
business entities
that receives grants and it refers
specifically to those organizations that
receive grants from the state of new
hampshire
um is there
a motion on this representative terosian
thank you madam chair
i make a motion of in
to legislate for house bill 1252 is
there a second
i'll say that
thank you representative sweeney would
you like to speak to your motion
representative terosian yes thank you
so i actually like many parts of this
bill
i think the intent is good
i certainly
don't think it's good practice for
businesses to take state money and then
contribute money to candidates that are
going to ensure you know in particular
in a grant that are going to ensure that
that grant continues
so however the
as the language is written it's just too
broad
so
i
hope that the
uh
sponsor and or other people next term
considered bringing something back that
that i could support with title language
but at this time it's it's not doable so
hence the motion of itl thank you
does anybody else want to speak to the
motion
seeing nothing i'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes mark says yes
representative terozian yes
representative barry yes representative
braun yes representative kweily yes
representative los ellis
yes representative alexander yes
representative bergeron yes
representative wilhelm yes
representative ward yes
representative perez yes
representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative freitas
yes
representative hamlet yes
representative murrehead
yes
madam chair yes
i'm sure the vote is 20 to 0. thank you
hb 1252 will be reported out of
committee to the body as inexperienced
in it an expedient to legislate it will
not seeing any objection it will go on
the consent calendar
the next bill we have scheduled for a
vote is
1383 requiring absentee ballot lists be
provided
to requesting parties within one
business day
does anybody want to speak to this
representative barry yes madam chairman
i'm asking the committee for a
continuance on this i'll have the final
amendment i believe early next week
as i spoke to it at length we're trying
to
address the issues that we introduced
this new thing last election uh last
municipal election and we're trying to
work out the uh
the issues um so that it's a it's a more
streamlined process for the town clerks
and the supervisors just the town clerks
so that we can all we can execute the
attention of the legislation that we
passed without having to overburden them
all right i am going to honor that
request and we are going to continue
executive session on 1383 to
allow time for further work
the next bill scheduled is 1567
and
i am actually asking the
letting the committee know that i am
asking for a continuance and going to
reschedule this so i can work on an
amendment for this you already have an
this spill is in regards to the removal
of election officials from office
this bill was amended to try to address
the amendment we have some of the
concerns that were brought to us in uh
public
the public hearing on this
however i i think there are some other
things that maybe might be appropriate
to try to do in regards to the
performance of duties of by election
officials within
their own municipality that may stop
short of removal and i would like an
opportunity to explore to see if an
amendment could be done so with that
our executive session for today is
finished
going forward committee members as you
know we have session next week on the
session for this committee next week
we have
actually and i don't quite know how this
happened i believe we have one bill left
for public hearing i don't know quite
how my scheduling managed to do that
so 1163 relative to over voted ballots
unless somebody remembers the public
well no no we have other i'm talking
about public hearings
so we have one bill that we have not had
a public hearing on as far as the
records show
and we have
uh exact at this point about half of our
bills
so i am anticipating a meeting either
the last week in february or the first
week in march as soon as i said it i
will let you know regardless of getting
things into the calendar to deal with
the last public hearing an executive
session on on i'm hoping many of the
bills
and then we will be having one meeting
either the 9th or 10th
of march after town meetings
most town meetings will have occurred
because our report out date is the 10th
um so it will have to be the 9th or the
10th but i there are certain bills that
i think
might be appropriate for the committee
to address after town meetings occur so
that is a plan i will let you know as
soon as i have figured out when we're
going to meet the last week in february
first week in march and i will let you
know as soon as i figure out whether it
is the 9th or the 10th and with that
thank you very much for coming today uh
this meeting is adjourned thank you for
our uh substitutes around the table for
joining us today we hope you had a good
time and if they ask you you'll come
secretary of
state can't believe that was
20 to 0.
it was 11 to 9.
that's what i thought yeah yeah for some
reason i didn't write that one down 11
to 9.
you